hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream number 147 which is
a pseudo prime number it's not prime no
it's not prime it's just pseudo Prime
just like it should be prime so seems
like it should be present that's why
they're a different thing I don't think
as we were talking about in the long run
up too today uh we are incidentally
Heather Hein and Brett Weinstein I was I
was gonna explain that talking about how
it's three less than 150 and 150 being a
multiple of three clearly it's not prime
but 49 by three seven by seven by three
method you've got there yeah I'm gonna
have to adopt that method
there will be fewer pseudo primes if I
do don't no this is not a good category
no not a good category that's not a good
category but you know the the Era of
Good categories is over no wrong here we
are part of the reason we come to you
every week is in defense of this is this
sounds banal and uninteresting but in
defense of good categories in defense of
the concept that there are real
categories in the universe that are
therefore both
that can be understood and are therefore
worth offending as categories well I
know from people who come up to me and
say this and I know they come up to you
and say this also that uh the role we
seem to be playing is keeping people
sane now I notice that nobody ever says
we made them saying right it's a matter
of uh preserving us
holding on to what sanity they still
have rather than generating or
bootstrapping sanity from nothing
um so anyway that's something we might
take up later but
um for the moment keeping people same
seems like a reasonable investment yes
and in service of that we have uh in
addition to these live streams we have
guest episodes that uh Brett is putting
out you've got two now with members of
the military and former current and
former members of the military
whistleblowers whistleblowers from the
military with regard to vaccine mandates
uh covert vaccine mandates in the
military uh you've got another guest
episode coming in
[Music]
um also in service of hopefully keeping
people sane and maybe bringing people
into a greater understanding of how to
maintain sanity and live in this crazy
hyper novel world we have 100 gatherer's
Guide to the 21st century which uh which
is being published in all sorts of cool
languages that we don't speak so we just
have to take their word for it that it's
that it's being translated right I just
saw the cover for the Chinese Edition
and it's got a whale on it and I was
asked to okay we're not okay the cover
and I said I I guess it's a it's a nice
whale although I don't really get the
connection but
yeah it's it's I was like as long as
it's about whales and not wailing which
we are not in favor of uh then uh then
okay yeah well I mean if you're in
sufficient pain wailing is Justified but
spelled differently
I'm not sure if that's a feature or a
bug in this case I think that may be a
good thing yes point of view of that uh
particular pun yep okay so we are on
YouTube and odyssey uh chat is live on
Odyssey if you're watching live uh other
other things that we or one of us does
that we hope that you can use to help
keep yourself sane and uh share with
others uh is Natural Selections which is
my sub stack this week I published what
I called a PSA a public service
announcement to Mama bears uh to defend
your children in it I point out that
mothers being women are more likely to
be both agreeable which is a term of Art
in Psychology uh referring to uh being
less likely to rock the boat and
disagree with those in front of you and
um
also
uh that women are more likely to behave
in ways that reduce harm and that reduce
risk and that both of these Tendencies
are being gamed by authorities and
others uh to convince women that the
very things that are harming children
are the things that are not harming them
and thus mothers in particular I feel
are being gamed and so I implore women
to uh to start asking questions of what
they are hearing from everyone you know
us authorities everyone and and come to
your own conclusions and at the point
that you discover even if your days
weeks months years into affirming or
complying with something that you come
to understand is harming your children
stop
stop it and and reverse course and even
if this means in in the moment your
child or children are going to be upset
with you and it's going to cause
um it's going to wreak havoc in the
moment consider
the truth of a year from now five years
from now 10 years from now what are the
conversations you will have if and I use
those words advisedly if you affirm your
child's declared gender identity or you
comply with the injunctions to give your
children experimental Medical Treatments
against a disease that doesn't really
affect them then uh you know stop and
think about it and so in in that that's
on my that's on Natural Selections this
week let me just say I think that I have
not read your piece yet I was as you
know in transit and which we will talk
about we will talk about it but anyway I
haven't read your piece but I really
like your framing this is the first I've
heard it that basically maternal
instincts are being gamed in other words
maternal instincts are being and really
used female instincts specifically yeah
yeah but they're being flipped on their
head they're being used in a paradoxical
way to do exactly the opposite of what
they are there for right the protection
of children is being compromised by the
misapplication of these maternal
instincts that matches exactly what I've
seen yeah um thank you and I mean
obviously I think it's right it's what
I'm it's what I'm proposing and you know
there are many people who are saying
things like this
uh but you know specifically for
instance the idea that if you do not
affirm your your child's new declaration
that they are the sex that they are not
they might commit suicide and then hell
will you live with yourself well I would
say look carefully into those claims and
ask yourself if you allow your child to
take puberty blockers or cross-sex
hormones or get surgery they will be
compromised forever and then how will
you live with yourself like that that
that is the harm that you can actually
avoid so
um all of which you know I encourage you
to to go look at that piece and I also
made the audio read of that my audio
read of that piece publicly available
um not just for paying subscribers this
week usually the audio reads if we're
paying subscribers only
um but the the little piece of graphic
that I made and Zach you can show now uh
to go along with the audio piece doing
on a firm don't comply uh we are we've
turned into merch
um which because we don't yet have our
new studio we can't um just show you on
the site uh just yet but I want to say
so do not a firm do not comply Dark
Horse shirts are are going to be
available at some point within the next
few minutes on our new store um shirts
hoodies uh and the like and uh in
service of that I also wanted to say a
few things about our new store sure
because we uh we mentioned a couple
months ago I think that we have a new
store and I didn't really say much more
we had a cat fight in the in the
background here
um
that we're just so thrilled to be
working with these guys uh it's it's a
small uh family operation it's a couple
just like we are running out their own
business uh out of the middle of the
country out of out of Kentucky
um and they are uh they're just they're
just awesome they um are an independent
small business who are supporting uh
independent voices uh if you have any
ever have a problem uh with an order you
reach out to them you're going to reach
a real human being one of their small
Team all of them are awesome and they
themselves are Dark Horse fans is how we
came to be familiar with them so uh we
have you know shared interests shared
values and basically when you know if
you see something there if you just want
Dark Horse uh branded merchandise or do
not affirm do not comply shirt or you
know they've actually got their own
print shop too so they're doing all the
printing and the embroidering in-house
so the quality control is extraordinary
the quality is high and the quality
control is excellent yeah the quality is
very high the quality control is that
excellent and so if you want that you
you no longer have to get that through
some sort of big uh amorphous Anonymous
thing you are supporting us but you're
also supporting another small business
um uh that is both a a media a media
management operation and uh and a print
shop so we we encourage you to do that
and that's at darkhorsestore.org
okay uh we are supported by our audience
through you know uh the ads that we run
which we'll get to the three ads that we
run at the beginning uh uh every week
and through
um people paying to access Natural
Selections through our patreons tomorrow
we have our private q a our monthly
private q a on my patreon next week we
will have you will have your private
conversations on your patreon and
you know we no longer make money the way
that people usually do if you're seeing
us on YouTube we're not we're not we
were monetized and we got demonetized by
YouTube and we'll be talking a little
bit today actually again as we have
before about misinformation and
disinformation
um but we were demonetized uh presumably
because some some intern there imagined
that we were guilty of Mr disinformation
and uh and you know we weren't
all right I don't think it was an intern
but okay
um and we you know we continue to be
demonetized by by YouTube uh so as such
we encourage you to join us at our
patreons or on my sub stack or any other
way that you you can and uh and also if
you are interested in any of the ads
that we the sponsors that we read ads
for please do consider going there we
actually are very very Discerning and we
only read we only take sponsors uh who
make products or offer services that we
really truly stand for so without
further Ado here we go with the ads for
this week
foreign sponsor this week is seed seed
is a company focused on bacteria and the
microbiome and they have a terrific
probiotic called ds01 daily symbiotic I
always prefer eating real food to taking
pills what I have to say I really love
this product there are a lot of things
that you can do to enhance your health
our sign off here at Dark Horse includes
three of them be good to the ones you
love eat good food and get outside but a
lot is hidden in those words what for
instance constitutes good food good food
is real food whole food food that has
been alive recently and was grown with
care and conditions as ancient as
possible given the constraints of the
21st century but even even many people
who eat such a diet are missing
something we contain multitudes every
individual human contains so many other
organisms some of which may harm us but
many of which exist with us in harmony
we need them this is why probiotics can
be an important tool in a healthy
lifestyle even if you eat nutrient-dense
food and avoid processed foods and sugar
that said probiotics are kind of the new
thing aren't they everyone's taking them
or thinking of taking them it can seem
like maybe it's just a fad the newest
fashion good news though seeds dso1
daily symbiotic is the real deal not all
probiotics are created equal seeds dso1
daily symbiotics a broad spectrum true
two in one probiotic and Prebiotic it
contains 24 distinct probiotic strains
in a two in one capsule and this is this
is the magic that protects the
probiotics until they hit the colon
where they are most effective if you've
taken a probiotic before or not really
felt the difference it's likely because
the good bacteria basically got
dissolved in your stomach acid before
they hit your colon see this design
differently and that's why it works
seeds daily symbiotic supports gut skin
and heart health and micronutrient
synthesis many who have used seed report
improvements to digestive function in 24
to 48 hours I've actually heard from
some of these some of these people it's
quite impressive
start a new healthy habit today visit
seed.com Darkhorse and use code
Darkhorse to redeem 20 off off your
first month of seeds DSO one daily
symbiotic that's seed.com s-e-eed.com
Darkhorse and use code Darkhorse
okay our second sponsor today is soul
s-o-l-e a sustainable Orthopedic
footwear company
Seoul is one of our two Footwear
sponsors and we truly love them both
they are they're basically between the
two of them they're the only shoes we
wear anymore practically they are quite
different from one another yet both have
an evolutionary approach to creating
shoes that help get and stay healthy and
people become more mobile Soul
intentionally brings structure back with
both their shoes and their footbeds so
aims with its Footwear to return our
feet to health and the shoes by Soul are
beautiful I've been wearing a pair of
Soul districts a low zip short boot and
camel colored vegetable tan suede
leather everywhere and I love them soft
footbeds are the industry standard and
over-the-counter supportive insoles and
inserts they are moldable for custom
comfort give you all the benefits of
personalized support at a fraction of
the price of orthotics soil footbeds
which are made from recycled Quark
include a signature supportive Arch
which is clinically proven to produce
Arch strain in your feet up to 34 this
is especially effective in helping
recover from plantar fasciitis which
affects more than 2 million Americans
along with a range of other ailments
from shin splints to hip knee and back
pain sole footbeds also promote neutral
alignment and good posture and are
particularly effective at preventing
fatigue when standing for long hours on
hard surfaces
the cats do not wear soul uh but if they
could I'm sure they would
so is on a mission to end foot pain in
North America so they are sending a free
footbed to every zip code on the
continent Dark Horse listeners should
visit yoursoul.com Darkhorse and if you
live in a zip code in the US or a postal
code in the Canada where Seoul hasn't
yet shipped to you'll receive a free
performance medium footbed they believe
in the quality of their product so much
that they're sure that once you feel the
Comfort pain relief permits and
performance enhancement and injury
prevention
prevention benefits of sole foot beds
you will want them in every shoe that
you own
simply enter your ZIP code or postal
code in the shipping section at checkout
to stand a chance to get a totally free
footbed while supplies last and if your
footbed isn't free because soil has
already shipped to your zip you can
still get 50 off by entering Dark Horse
50 at checkout
so far Seoul has shipped to 38 percent
of the 41 000 ZIP codes in the U.S so
they've got a lot of giving to do help
push those percentages by visiting
yoursoul.com Dark Horse today
all right our final sponsor this week is
Ned a CBD company that stands out in a
highly saturated CBD Market Ned was
started by two friends who discovered
their hyper modern lives were leaving
them feeling empty bewildered and
disconnected something about this way of
life they say on their website just
wasn't working so they started Ned you
can buy CBD products in nearly every
coffee shop or grocery store but Ned's
Blends stand out and now I'm going to
speak as if I was you I'm not going to
do my devastatingly good impression of
you I'm just going to use your words do
you have one that's so good really I've
never heard it yeah you keep it from me
it's uh it's it's it'll freak you out
hearing yourself as if you're standing
in front of you I don't believe you yeah
I don't really either
um
but anyway here's what you've said
you've said I am particularly fond of
their de-stress blend Ned's de-stress
blend is a one-to-one formula of CBD CBG
made from the world's purest full
spectrum hemp and also features a
Botanical infusion of ashwagandha
cardamom and cinnamon CBG is known as
the mother of all cannabinoids because
of how effective it is at combating
anxiety and stress by inhibiting the
reuptake of Gaba the neurotransmitter
responsible for stress regulation this
combination leaves me Heather feeling a
bit easier with whatever comes my way
many of the CBD companies out there
Source their hemp from Individual Farms
individual what other kind are there
industrial farms in China just like low
quality alcohol however low quality CBD
can have undesired effects Ned is USDA
certified organic all of Ned's full
spectrum hemp oil is extracted from USDA
certified organic hemp plants grown by
an indefinite independent farmer named
Jonathan in Paonia Colorado you're going
to call them indefensible weren't you
Jonathan I apologize if I was going to
call you that it was an error all right
also Ned shares third-party lab reports
and information about who forms their
products and their extraction process on
their site these products are
science-backed nature-based solutions
that offer an alternative to
prescription and over-the-counter drugs
they are chock full of Premium CBD and
full spectrum of active cannabinoids
terpenes flavonoids and trichomes Ned's
full spectrum hemp oil nourishes the
body's endocannabinoid system to offer
functional support for stress sleep
inflammation and balance if you'd like
to give Ned a try Dark Horse listeners
get 15 off Ned products with the code
Darkhorse visit
helloned.com Dark Horse to get access or
hell on Ed is another way you could
pronounce that h e l l o n e d.com slash
Darkhorse to get 15 off thank you Ned
for sponsoring the show and offering our
listeners a natural remedy for some of
life's most common health issues hello
Ed hello on Ed
all right
um that's our that's our sponsors so uh
today we are going to talk about a
number of things and Brett you are going
to start us off
um by uh talking a little bit about
where you've been or what you've seen
and what it means yeah so I had the
pleasure of visiting a country that I
have been to exactly once and only
briefly before I was in Colombia
um I was invited to give a talk at a
medical conference conference was
fascinating I met very interesting
people and I will say I had a number of
thoughts about
um
Colombia now having visited the last
time I was there was
it was definitely 1997 or 1998 I cannot
remember exactly which I don't think it
much matters but at the time
there was exactly one place a gringo
could go in Colombia and if you even
stepped out of that place the risk of
being kidnapped was incredibly high this
is not like when they tell you oh don't
be out after dark in Managua where you
have a high risk of being robbed but
your risk is still you know a tiny
fraction of one percent this was if you
step out of the Zone where you are
protected by the military the likelihood
of you being captured by the farc and
being uh having being held for ransom
was through the roof
um can I just say the reason you ended
up and it was Cartagena is part of the
place that you ended up
um the reason that you ended up there is
that uh you were doing research in
Panama and in Central America unlike the
places that we've been in South America
um unless you have a long-term Visa
which are very hard to get uh in Central
America you have to leave the country
every I think it's 90 days maybe but you
just have to leave the country for like
72 hours and then you can come back in
and get another 90-day Visa
um whereas in
at least the places we've been in South
America there's a there's a cap on the
number of days that uh that an American
for instance can spend in the country
per calendar year and you can't you
can't get around it like that but you
had gone with a couple of the people you
knew from Bridal Colorado Island where
you were doing research to Cartagena for
72 hours to deal with your to deal with
the VISA it's interesting you said I
don't remember that being the case that
that's why I did it you're right about
the pattern it may have been somebody
else in my group needed to do it and
they were you know Panama and Colombia
are bordering in fact Panama used to be
part of Colombia
um and it was inexpensive to go it's
possible I've just forgotten that I was
I mean they were there you were there
for so many months you had to do a
number of those trips and that was one
of them yeah but in any case I was in
Cartagena I didn't really know what
Cartagena was when I was there I was
delighted by the place it's a beautiful
Colonial City very well preserved
um so it was lovely but I actually I was
walking down the beach in Cartagena one
day and I was stopped by a soldier who
was like yeah don't you can't go beyond
this Jetty right this is the end of
where Gringos can go
um so anyway now and he wasn't saying
because I'm the authority and I have a
gun and I'm the big bad man he was like
you're gonna get hurt yeah yeah and
you're gonna get disappeared and I you
know having now returned to Colombia I
asked Colombians if that was an
exaggeration and everybody validated the
story that this was that dangerous so I
think
the most dangerous
place on Earth for at least those from
from the from the United States but
anyway so here I was returning uh in
2022 and which I should say It was
supposed to be us right we were invited
to give this talk absolutely and uh as
it turns out it was uh there was stuff
to do parenting-wise back home and so we
decided it could have been you it could
have been me we decided that you should
go so you were there yep and uh and tell
us about it so
number of things are true one it is
amazing and I think there's some lesson
here for all of us right we are watching
our civilization do some very bizarre
and truly dangerous things but it is
worth understanding that a place like
Colombia that was literally uh
impossible to go to because of the
danger is now quite hospitable now I was
told that there was a certain amount of
danger
walking around not so much from things
like the farc who apparently still exist
and so they do harass people well
they've been driven
farther from uh inhabited places is my
understanding they've been driven
effectively farther into the jungle by a
concerted military effort
um and so the danger is more about uh
petty crime and things like that
I must say I didn't feel that danger
um at all I walked around as much as I
could in Bogota and then later in the
back country which I'll tell you about
but
anyway it was there's something profound
about being in a place that you
literally couldn't go at an earlier
point and now being able to walk around
freely and you do see police presence
all over the place
um I was I probably shouldn't have been
surprised at how different it felt from
Ecuador very close together of course
and they there's some similar things
about them the capitals and the Andes
and they have uh you know lowland
tropical forest and all so there's some
things about the country that are
superficially similar but it really
there was only one or two places that it
really felt like yeah this could be
Ecuador so that was that was interesting
I am very excited for us at some point
to explore well for me to get to
Colombia but for us to also get to
Venezuela and Bolivia as well as Peru
yeah because Ecuador Bolivia and
Venezuela
I want to say Ecuador and Bolivia for
sure and maybe parts of Peru and parts
of Bolivia are sort of understood to be
much more similar uh and and yet you
know Ecuador has so many different
ancient cultures and um and modern
ecosystems as well so it's not it is
both surprising and not surprising that
uh Colombia which as you say is
superficially similar in terms of being
a South American country with you know
with high Andean all the way to
Amazonian ecosystems
um and uh and a capital that you were in
in the Andes at altitude
um should you know be reminiscent to
some degree but also wildly different
yeah uh reminiscent but wildly different
and you know when I think about that the
difference between American states right
you know you and west of the Cascades
and Washington feels different from
Idaho right right and even west of the
Cascades from you know east of the
Cascades is right that's exactly it yeah
it's radically different so anyway it's
maybe not as surprising as as I was
surprised
um but I I noticed some interesting
things first of all
um Colombia had serious covid mandates
and travel restrictions which it has
recently lifted I was which was why we
weren't going to go originally yeah I
was required to have a negative covid
test within I think 24 hours of travel
to get into the country and they did ask
me for it so that is still there but
there was no other restriction but I
noticed the following interesting
pattern
I saw
far more people wearing masks than I
would say is true anywhere in the United
States that I've been really in the last
six months
um which if you were to compare between
American states I would say that masks
were a really good proxy for how crazy
people were over covet narrative right
at this point yeah this was absolutely
not the case in Colombia in fact the
pattern was
random as far as I could tell you would
frequently see people
walking down the street
talking enjoying life and one was
wearing a mask and the other wasn't
wearing a mask they're outdoors and I I
began to puzzle over this because you
know it's such a you know a flash point
in our culture you know whether you are
or aren't on board with whatever the
narrative is that you know it's really
it's it's Wrecking relationships and
there was no sign of that here so the
question is really why if there's no
sign of that if people don't you know if
one person who believes in The Mask
isn't feeling the need to implore their
friend oh you should wear it too because
you might get coveted and it'll be this
that and the other what is going on was
it always so I mean I have I have seen
pairs of people walking down the street
in you know west west of the mountains
on the west coast uh in which one is
master and one is not uh I think every
time the woman is masked and the man is
not when when it is a couple like that
is that a pattern that you noticed uh I
would say it was more women than men but
it was there was really very little
signal that I could find maybe there was
signal and I just didn't figure it out
but anyway I also know some other things
um that I think are connected and I'll
tell you what I put together which I did
run by my host and he he I think thought
it was credible but the doctor who put
together the conference who I don't I
don't know if we asked him if we could
mention him I feel confident we can uh
at least just say uh Dr Ben
um so what the other thing I noticed was
that
Colombians
were very much going on about their
lives there was much less of a sense of
coveted trauma having Disturbed normal
patterns this looked like Latin
Americans doing what Latin Americans do
right I was there over a weekend in
Bogota people were
dancing not only were they dancing in
places where dancing was the thing but
you know couples would get up and they
were dancing in a cafe because the song
that was playing delighted them or
whatever so people were falling in love
they were holding hands they were
dancing they were singing they were
there was a great uh I
had to work a little bit to find an
authentic food place and I was uh
getting dinner there in the place
because you were staying in like
conference land yeah unfortunately I was
in conference land yeah so it was a long
walk to anywhere but
um but
there was a great really good band
playing a lot of this is at the
Colombian Steakhouse that you found yeah
they were they were next door and they
were playing lots of uh
Latin rock songs that I didn't recognize
but that were compelling and then
occasional covers of songs that I you
know both know and like I can't name off
the top of my head what the Colombian
music oh we got a cat with something in
his mouth here if uh if that is worth
dealing with it
um we're doing a little predation
interlude here
yeah uh so you know I'm just thinking
okay I can you know there there are
there are known musical traditions in I
assume every Latin American country and
I don't off the top of my head no
uh I'm embarrassed to say I don't know
for sure I'm wondering if Cumbia is uh
is actually the the club but I guess I
didn't mean to put you on the spot at
all I was wondering if you felt like you
were hearing something that was
Colombian specific or if it was sort of
you know Latin American rock it was
young modern sophisticated Rock and the
things that they chose to cover
reflected the same thing so like you
know Radiohead that's not the average
band you hear covered yeah
um but here it was
um so anyway
life looked surprisingly normal The
Masks were completely at odds with that
interpretation and what I concluded was
Colombians have lived
um under
various kinds of tyranny lots of it
driven by American drug policy great
right so they've lived under
basically a regime in which they lack
control at the large scale and so what I
concluded was that what I was watching
was people who had learned to sort of
send whatever signal you need to send to
Authority so that it leaves you alone
enough that you can live in the
interstitial space and that's your life
and if you know if if decades at a time
are going to be lived under a tyrannical
regime you have to figure out how to do
the stuff of Life under its nose without
getting its attention yeah this is
actually consistent with um the next new
piece of art that we have coming out
that's going to be on merchandise that
we're working with our amazing artists
on right now which emerges from a line
that you gave I think at the end of the
last live stream or maybe it was two
live streams ago which is lie to a
tyrant yeah right it's like you know
what do what you have to do
uh to you know to be real and honest and
uh and what it sounds like what you're
saying even though there's not a
particular Tyrant uh here that you're
referring to whether I told Colombia uh
like you know give the little nod to the
authorities and then get on with your
life and then get on with your life you
know like in between places that it's
watching right so anyway I thought this
was great this sort of
um a sort of reminded me both the fact
of Colombia having gone from a place
that was totally unsafe to a place that
is now safe enough that at least I
didn't feel threatened walking around
yeah
um that is heartening right they've gone
from a regime that was completely
intolerable you know at the height of
the drug war and uh the the farc
revolution
um to a state that is totally
recognizable and you know I mean let's
put it this way
um life there
is crazy and the people there are crazy
but they're not as crazy as we are right
we're all crazy all people all these
cultures have their own idiosyncrasies
and so what's the what's I I guess I
didn't expect you to say that what's the
crazy that you think you do see well I
mean first of all this this is this is
another topic we're talking about there
is a way in which in Latin America you
and I have seen this so many different
ways
life is unfortunately cheap and it's
very disturbing to see it right the the
uh exhaust that comes out of a truck
that you can't get out from behind is
absolutely toxic and it's not even
regulations nobody's even notices it
it's so ubiquitous that it's just like
well what would I even do to notice that
some toxin is being spewed into the car
I'm traveling right
um people interestingly
people a huge percentage of the
population on the roads is on
motorcycles right
a lot of people aren't wearing helmets
people are you know women with their you
know seven-year-old kid on the
motorcycle going to school right all
sorts of stuff that would jar you if you
saw it here
um is commonplace I saw one very funny
instance
um we were out in the in the back
country really quite remote and a child
on a motorcycle he must have been 12
years old at most on a full-size adult
motorcycle just him just him uh bear he
had no shirt on as I recall it certainly
no helmet right nothing like protective
gear right he's on this bumpy road yep
he's got two pieces of rough hewn lumber
from obviously the local Mill like
dimensional Lumber but rough few really
rich what kind of boards you would see
you know used to siding yeah siding make
a roof something
um but anyway he had the front of these
boards which were probably eight feet
long ten feet long tied to the back of
the motorcycle and the back is dragging
on the ground and he was just motoring
by yeah I mean it was Charming he
definitely solved the problem of how
you're gonna get the lumber home but
um you know there was a way in which
there was so much
and also I I have to say I just can't
even solve this puzzle
somehow these back roads in Colombia
there is always exactly enough room for
whatever two vehicles have just met to
pass there's like you know three or four
centimeters beyond that but it doesn't
matter right it could be two cars it's
three or four centimeters if you're up
in the 80s are you sometimes there's
like a precipitous drop on one side or
were you not enough oh yeah there was
all kinds of well I mean at the very
least there are gullies where if you
were you know a few centimeters too far
you might end up sliding over and being
stuck there all night but sitting over
in stock is different from phone yeah
I'm falling into the abyss right no it's
definitely preferable I think so without
being all the way at good you know
but okay so there's a way in which
um life is cheap in a way that is
familiar from the developing world but
what really struck me was that I was now
that familiar there's nothing I can do
about the danger so I'm just not going
to let it rule my life thing that
happens in the developing world I am now
detecting that in the so-called first
world life has become very very cheap oh
um well I mean if you think about all
the things that have taken place during
covid
um the fact that
you've got you know
huge numbers of Adverse Events the Press
isn't very interested in figuring out
what they are you know we're kind of not
doing autopsies unless we absolutely
have to there's a way in which
um you know we're normalizing
absurdly tragic deaths right very young
people so you know young people
sudden adult death syndrome strikes
again
um and so anyway
there's always you know that jarring
comparison between your culture and
really any other culture I mean it even
exists with the tiny little distinctions
between US and Canada and the bigger the
gap between your culture and somebody
else's the more profound the comparison
is but these comparisons now are
revealing things a
we're more traumatized than the
Colombians by what we've just been
through right maybe they were toughened
up by what they went through in the
period before
well it sounds like
I actually don't know but I know like we
were also told that we must accept
more stupid things so they were told to
mask and they were at least vaccine
mandates for visitors but and I don't
know specifically about this so it's
possible I'm wrong here but I know that
in many of the Latin American countries
Ecuador Mexico uh Costa Rica I believe
and I and I think this is pretty much
across the board that early treatment
was available over the counter for from
the beginning basically that there was
no attempt and I remember like the The
Head of State in El Salvador was busy
talking about vitamin D early on too
yeah but you know the the drugs that you
know we shall never mention by name for
fear that we somehow become
re-demonetized even though we were still
demonetized
um were just available and people were
using them and they were even in
um they were even being given out by
governments in Mexico
um as you know understood to be early
treatment and in some cases prophylaxis
packs so you know that you know it's
possible that some Latin American
country didn't do that but I don't know
that to be the case and so
um even if young many people are still
masked and we know there have been
vaccine requirements uh until recently
at least for visitors that doesn't mean
the degree to which basically the
gaslighting of the populace was
happening at the same level that it was
in the United States and Canada and the
UK and Australia and New Zealand
basically the English-speaking countries
of the Western World had such an
extraordinary degree of gaslighting such
an extraordinary degree of like well if
you're trying to figure out what's going
on you must be guilty of missed this and
Mal information so we're going to shut
you down and it just went it just went
counter to everything and and I think to
your point and that was such a switch
from what we had come to expect
whereas the Colombians having been
effectively held hostage by not a
government but a
set of organizations that were outside
of the government for so many years came
to figure out how to sort of
pretend to pay Allegiance and then go on
with their lives
yeah I think this is
quite the case that effectively under
tyranny I think I believe this under
tyranny one is always gaslit and if you
have had enough of that in your history
so that you've kind of gotten used to
the idea that certain channels are
compromised and they'll say stuff to you
and it may even govern what you have to
do but privately you don't have to
believe it right that that gives you a
kind of immunity and what happened in in
the United States at least was that
people
were used to these channels being noisy
but they were not anywhere near prepared
for the order of magnitude of [ __ ]
that flowed through them and so you know
I mean this really is what the big lie
means right the big lie is the LIE is so
big that you can't imagine it's a lie
because it just it's beyond uh what
would incredibly be misrepresented right
and actually this goes to another point
which you know it put me in a weird spot
the day I gave my talk was the day that
the CDC
that's you know it's very hard to
describe this with enough Precision to
be perfectly accurate but the CDC
recommended to the states that they put
the not even actually so the CDC put
together a a committee of 15 people who
voted unanimously to recommend that the
CDC then recommend to the states and so
wolinski still had to sign off and of
course she did yeah but the unanimous
vote by the 15-0 committee to I didn't
mean we didn't get to punchline too
um put the coveted vaccines on the
recommended schedule for childhood
vaccinations was what happened
yes so it's almost impossible to even
describe the committee recommended that
the CDC recommend to the states that
they require children to get these
vaccines in order to go to school and
all right sorry but like already the
fact Checkers like well people are
saying that now it's going to be
required by the states and I actually go
into this in my in my sub stack this
week it's like you know this is what
happens now unless you speak 100
carefully
um you get facts checked out of
existence and what the fact Checkers
never say because they are actually
political agents and not fact Checkers
at all is actually even under the best
of conditions in which the states are
really being honorable and careful and
trying to do the right thing which of
course is not the case but even under
those conditions the cdc's
recommendation is what you follow like
you have to actually go well outside of
um of what is expected to say uh
actually I'm gonna I'm gonna do
something different and of course you
know Florida is doing something
different they're getting no end of [ __ ]
for it right well okay okay I'm just
gonna
I'm just gonna say it do it um I am so
sick of fact Checkers I am totally ready
for fact chess right can we just go up a
level nice yes all right and then and
then four dimensional effect chest oh
wouldn't that be something man I mean
that's what's being done to us actually
yeah
yeah well okay so
while I was there preparing to give my
talk uh the the keynote actually the
conference yep the plenary
um
the CDC went through this charade and it
was you know it was thoroughly absurd
right these did you see the video of the
votes uh no I didn't watch the these
were
Zoom Gatherings which person after
person masked on their Zoom assembly
from their own home right these are True
Believers oh my God who have now
recommended or they just they know it's
theater
I think these were True Believers it's
worth looking at the video but I mean
true but true believers in WoW True
Believers in the cult that is now doing
so and here's the Crux of it right I
feel like this recommendation actually
crosses a boundary that for some they
will follow it across but for almost
anybody who's still got any independent
mental capacity at all the idea that
with a disease as age stratified as
covid in the hazard it poses and a
vaccine age stratified in the other
direction for its Hazard the absurdity
of recommending these vaccines for
children is
unmistakable yeah no I mean this is I
know you haven't read it yet but this is
exactly what I was writing about in
Natural Selections this week it is
exactly this I mean that that was this
is actually a piece that I had written
many weeks ago and I was like I'm just
looking for the right examples and we
got two of the right examples with
regard to trans and with regard to
Childhood vaccinations this week I was
like okay there it is
yeah but at some level
this is now an unmistakable atrocity yes
right we are not talking about an
ambiguity we are talking about
recommending treatments that are
dangerous and in fact most dangerous for
the population in question here we're
talking about
denying people education for refusing
them for for behaving reasonably we are
going to deny people education that
isn't that is like
ghastly at an incredible level that this
would happen to children and then for
the CDC to play its game
well we're not requiring these things we
don't have the authority to do or not
we're not Heavens no we're not requiring
if you had never heard of us before
covet and now we're on everyone's the
tip of everyone's tongues but we
certainly don't have any Authority at
all how could we look at us all we did
was recommend if the states are gonna
you know recommendations or children
that's the state's problem right it's
just like it's amazing and even just the
mind-blowing fact of okay
let's understand the CDC let's take it
more or less at its word
why
because it is its own reducto ad
absurdum okay okay so if the idea is
well the CDC is just making a
recommendation the states of course make
their own judgments that's you know why
wouldn't the CDC under a democratic
regime be you know a championing states
rights right it's okay absurd on its
face but now let's imagine
that the states do what they are
apparently going to do you've got a
bunch of Rebel states that aren't going
to recommend these things and you've got
a bunch of states that are going to
engage in the usual slavish Devotion to
Authority and are going to require them
so now you've got a patchwork country in
which the
um
inexplicable
completely unnecessary harm to children
is going to be done on a state-by-state
basis those people who have the means to
move themselves out of states are going
to have an advantage over those who are
condemned to stay in the state that they
are in because of a job and the need for
it or who knows I mean and I'm you know
this in sort of with the opposite
political valence uh this is true with
regard to Reproductive Rights with
regard to abortion right so you know and
we've always had the division over
things like the Second Amendment over
Reproductive Rights over death penalty
but now for you know if the election
that's in a week and a half we've got
abortion and now childhood vaccination
um against covid
on you're on on everyone's minds and
there are a lot of us who find ourselves
pulled in opposite directions by these
two things by knowing that many states
are going to go stupid on covid and
preserve uh the right to at least early
term abortion for women and that other
states are going to preserve the right
to early term uh pregnancy termination
for women and or did I say that twice
did I say the same thing twice either
way like stupid on covid and um to my
mind smart and Reproductive Rights or
the opposite like either way you've got
to take one thing that that is not is
not sane and it's not
compassion is overused and it's
weaponized but it's not compassionate
well I'm
afraid it's worse than that
um
a
to the extent that what we have our
ideologies political ideologies or
political banners and that these banners
essentially have an incoherent package
of beliefs that comes with them things
that actually are not inherently related
to each other right
um but you know my team believes these
things and not those things and that
this is now going to become a geographic
phenomenon where there we are losing the
agreement that holds us together as a
nation this obviously leads in the
direction of some sort of dissolution of
that Nation
which is of course a extremely
short-sighted catastrophe and leaves
lots of us
stranded right stranded where we would
like to choose where to live as a
constitutionally protected right we
would like to choose where to live based
on things other than the ideology of the
governance structure that is the exact
opposite of living in a free country
where the the ideology of those in power
in your state is such a profound
influence in which you can and cannot do
and how you will and will not live that
it might cause you to have to move
between states that just I can't believe
we're here it's really it's really
stunning yep and both of these both of
these happened this year yeah and
um
those in power in States both in red
States and in blue states are making
decisions that are causing people to
flee and uh and now it is it is quite
clear uh that we've got
um
we've got political things running in
opposite directions with regard to uh to
the Slate to the teams that have been
agreed on and this you know this is this
is in part the problem of a two-party
system there are a lot of us
who you know for us we've always voted
blue but there are a lot of people
who've always voted red who are now
going like I can't do that anymore but I
can't go blue and I've always heard of
blue I can't do that anymore but I can't
go red like where where are the options
that actually represent
careful nuanced thought and care for
both individuals and recognizing that we
live in a society
and and are going to need some Society
level protections like where is that
party where are those politicians they
they exist like one person here one
person there we got Tulsi gabbard saying
I'm done with the Democrats
um but it's not as far as I know she
didn't say I'm becoming Republican
because like that's that's not an option
right like neither of these parties is
an option anymore for a very large
number of us all right so two two more
points one the division and now
increasing Geographic division right
profound enough to cause you to move
rather than just Grumble at the people
who run your state
um that thing is also causing the loss
of nuance in the positions even the
position that is closer to your own is
has lost Nuance because the point is the
people who constitute a natural break on
the perspective don't aren't in power
enough to matter right and so in other
words if it's one party rule in each
state right then what you get
is you know look I'm not
comfortable with uh the blue team's uh
complete abdication of responsibility
over Reproductive Rights as I've said
many times I believe the right to uh an
abortion exists and that right decreases
through the you said blue team yeah well
The Blue Team seems to think it's
sophisticated to imagine that there is
nothing morally interesting that happens
at all until the moment of birth I mean
and the point is well I don't think any
rational rational person believes that
but if the idea is you have to choose
between you know sacred zygotes the two
the two points conception and birth are
the only moments in uh in a human life
that matter at all right in discussing
whether or not abortion should be
allowed no sorry someone else set those
as the two moments are the ones we have
to be talking about and neither of them
is the right one they're both
intolerable and I'm not saying it you
know I actually think that the religious
perspective is tolerable at the
individual level an individual can
believe that coherently and a morally
consistent way but you can't apply it
across a population where religious
beliefs vary right that's not that's not
acceptable what's more
um you know as we talked about before
the idea that the sacredness of zygotes
is such that you have to
um you know that women have to carry the
product of rape to term right is it is
Bonkers because the point is this
actually generates a strategy for
rapists it's not what you know it's not
what you do
um so the lack of nuance on both sides
is a disaster and the idea is that now
we're going to have to pick your poison
like which which bad philosophy do you
want to live near or live under is is
not a good thing
so anyway the CDC made its move right
before I gave my talk and I felt
compelled actually
you know what kind of person would I be
if I saw a
a an atrocity a slow motion atrocity
unfolding in front of me a medical
atrocity and I didn't say so at a
medical conference so I took the risk
and I
told him exactly what I thought this
meant and exactly what it implies about
where we are in history and didn't know
how that was going to go over but it
actually I got lots and lots of positive
feedback over it I may at some point
make that uh piece I you know as you
know I don't usually I don't ever write
a talk in advance right I may have
noticed notes and know where I'm going
in this case first time in my life
I wrote it out word for word it really
needed to be precise so
um anyway that was interesting
um interesting that the conference you
know medical conference
full of people who uh I can't say that
they all shared the perspective but
enough of them did that you know the
feedback was not you're a crazy person
but it was whoa thank you for saying
that just to be clear it wasn't mostly
allopathic doctors it was mostly
naturopathic osteopaths yep yep it was a
heterodox conference for sure but you
know I I don't know what the total
number was a lot of people were uh
remote there were hundreds of people in
the room I think there was a thousand
yeah more than a thousand yeah um they
were attending some way in some way so
anyway that was that was fascinating
um
but
okay I guess I there's also maybe I
should just move on to the after the
conference was over
um my host uh
did me the honor of uh letting me join
his family on an adventure where he took
me deep into the Andes to a highly
unusual rock formation that
unfortunately I don't have any pictures
ready
um show but in any case basically the
you know it's cold high altitude Andes
there's a location the Andes are at
least in this spot and I think all over
are the result of C uplift so this is an
ancient sea floor
has been lifted
um you know thousands of meters so it's
going to be the Limestone yeah it's
Limestone cars and just um
you know people who haven't spent time
in the tropics at all
um or if they've only spent time in the
lowland Tropics like they went on a like
a jungle adventure to Costa Rica or
something uh we'll imagine simply that
the closer to the Equator you get the
hotter it is right
um but as is you know interesting and
relevant to things that we have
um thought and about and worked on and
specifically as you have worked on with
regard to Latitude diversity gradient
just as
um the biota gets more diverse the
closer to the Equator you get
um it also gets more diverse the closer
to sea level you get and that analogous
pattern is also consistent with uh the
farther from the equator and the farther
from sea level so both latitudinally and
altitudinally it gets colder and drier
and less diverse and so you could be
real close to the equator as you were
pretty close to the equator there but at
8 000 feet and it's really cold it's
quite cold and uh the biodiversity as
you point out goes down I mean it's
still plant-wise it was pretty diverse
um but you lose like the charismatic
Mega fun at first just like you know at
the polls you don't get a lot of
terrestrial you don't get diversity of
terrestrial uh megafauna yes except
except there are interesting exceptions
and one of my favorite creatures is an
exception
um there is an inverse altitudinal
gradient to a point there's obviously a
point at which you're so high it's not
true but
um the hummingbird diversity yes yes
goes uh down it's still there a fair
number of hummingbirds in the Amazon but
there are more of them at the mid and
semi-high elevations and I'm like three
to six thousand feet ish something like
that right cloud forest and even a
little bit a little bit into paramo but
it sort of they start to die off as you
get higher yeah yeah there there are
some you're at the edge in Paramount
actually Zach would you show some of
these uh creatures whatever order yeah
all right this is one of your
photographs yes can you move fantastic
uh yeah this actually so well this is
actually you can move the picture of us
to the other Corner this is in Bogota
is it
five six thousand feet something like
that yeah it's it's uh it's a it's above
five
um higher than Denver anyway I went to
the I was feeling uh I don't know I I
was having a nature deficit disorder
moment and I you know I was stuck in
Bogota I couldn't get out of Bogota far
enough to see stuff so I went to the
botanical gardens which were actually
spectacularly good it's really beautiful
um
no Bogota is actually at 86. really high
yeah yeah third highest capital in South
America after Kita on the pause
yeah it's uh it's up there so here wait
a minute
I'm gonna I'm gonna just check this I'm
not sure I believe this um you keep
going all right yeah so I went to the
Botanical Garden hoping to find nature
and I did find a couple interesting
things I found a secret tree a tree that
you and I are uh that's a big genus but
um you and I are well familiar with
sacropia it's an early successional tree
it puts out a fruit that's actually
slightly tasty certainly not bitter but
anyway bats and birds love it I don't
think there were any fruit bats at this
altitude in fact I'm sure there weren't
so just early successional means it
comes in early it grows fast it's what
is light it dies fast it you know yeah
and in this case sacropia is fast it
dies young yeah they're like Balsa which
is the one that most people will think
of when they think of like what's a
tropical wood that's not a hardwood that
you know you use that's light right
socropia is light not by virtue of the
wood being less dense but by these uh
cavities that are in every segment of
the tree right which get inhabited by
Aztec ants but anyway I found some
sacropias in the in the Botanical Garden
that were in fruit and there were lots
of birds flying in and out which was
cool but I wanted to find hummingbirds I
love hummingbirds and I love
photographing hummingbirds and I was
just not having any luck and then
finally I heard one in another corner of
the botanical garden and you hear that
like yeah
um and I uh I didn't think I was gonna
be able to chase it down I saw
it high in the tree you know no chance
of a photograph but at least I saw it
and then it moved down I started to
figure out its pattern you know where it
was going where it was feeding and
anyway I eventually
um
managed to get a couple of nice
photographs of it uh right before right
before sunset and so I'm gonna go to the
next picture
yeah it's not I have a hummingbird these
guys
um I am not a 100 certain let me tell
you what I saw and see if you can figure
it out well I don't have a clip
flycatchery
and what happened here so I think if
they were fly catchers it's just one
bird in this Photograph no there are two
birds you see the yellow breasted bird
oh that looks like a fruit from here
like I just this is so far away and so
small like this is this is not a fair
test for me you have to show me the
picture up close
nothing to do Bennett yeah um
anyway this second bird that has its
wings outstretched here was doing this
interesting thing that I took to be a
display it was hovering in front of this
other Bird that's sitting on a branch
now the thing though is these were both
Yellow Breasted so
I don't think it's a fly catcher because
I think the fly catcher is where I was
were dimorphic and so I think this has
to be two males somebody who's watching
is going to tell me that maybe maybe
I've got it wrong either these aren't
fly catchers or that this particular
flycatcher is a big big group
um I don't I have not
um
I've got a cool bird guide to uh the
birds of the Andes including Colombia
that but it's still in a box and I
didn't know that we were going to be
doing this but there are a lot of fly
catchers and flycatcher is if memory
serves a clade it's a description of
History rather than just a description
of ecology that's absolutely right uh
and I I believe that many places that
there are fly catchers in the Andes
there are multiple species that said
within a clade it would be very
interesting if some of them were
belligerous and some of them were
monogamous the the reason that's
relevant here is Udo is you said that
you think they're dimorphic if they're
dimorphic they're probably polishness if
they're not dimorphic if the males and
females look alike they're probably
monogamous yep yeah in fact monogamy is
common enough in birds that if the clade
has many species in this spot then
probably some of them are so anyway
maybe maybe this is male displaying in
front of a female but we'll find out
um okay go on
all right this is a large dragonfly
and go on
this is all Bogota or is this um no no
we are now uh actually in uh outskirts
of a town called via laba which is a
colonial well-preserved Colonial uh Town
kind of admission architecture it's a
very beautiful place
um
and uh so that was that was where the
that that potential fly catcher was this
guy is actually in the Limestone karst
location which is a near a town called
Pinon
um and anyway this particular uh photo
that's actually
um a plant that you and I have grown
it's hard to get it to flower but it's
crocosmia yeah and this hummingbird was
was feeding there which I thought was
really cool
um so that's that is a different
crocosmia than we have grown here in the
Pacific Northwest and I'm not surprised
that there are multiple crocosmias but
you also came back saying that you think
krakazmi is native to the Andes I asked
and one you know it's always difficult
to know you know whether they're telling
you that it's just found commonly in
people's Gardens or whether it's truly a
wild plant there but yes that's what
they they told me was at that plant is
uh wild in the area
um okay you want to go to the next one
and then here uh Edgar who was our
that's the name of the bird guide no no
the bird's not Edgar okay um Edgar uh so
it could be lovely gentleman who invited
me to you know he saw I was interested
in hummingbirds and he invited me to his
house where he had indeed he and his
wife have planted a tremendous number of
hummingbird plants which actually makes
the photographic job much more difficult
because you never know where the bird's
gonna be just the point of order uh that
looks like krakasmi is native to South
Africa oh there you go so that must mean
it's either I I can't imagine it's
invasive so it must be just grown
ornamentally
in the Andes
um okay so anyway he invited me over and
uh it made it really difficult one
species of synthetic to Madagascar
a little search engine is a dangerous
thing
yeah
all right I think that's all I have
photo wise it's beautiful and that's
that's
um I'd have to go back and look but I
think you've shown three different
species of hummingbirds absolutely I
think it was a violet tier and a Hermit
and uh forgotten what the third one is
um that's interesting you pronounce it
that way I look I think that I think of
it as the Violet ear because that's it's
named for the the purple splotch on the
ear I think Violet ears yeah whether I
made up the pronunciation or not
um
all right oh I didn't have a anecdote I
wanted to tell you awesome I thought it
was sort of it's a cognitively
interesting anecdote from from uh
Colombia okay we were driving down this
really
you know pretty typical back road which
is to say slow
um super bumpy Dragon lung pieces Lumber
behind you or not not a piece of lumber
attached to the vehicle anywhere
um we're driving along
and uh there is a rooster
by the side of the road nothing
interesting about that also all-time
different no didn't didn't catch the uh
the gentle bird's name but uh anyway the
rooster as we reach the rooster the
rooster lifted its head up from feeding
and darted in front of us nearly getting
smashed oh no and I shouted why
to a to a car full of people who speak
Spanish and French it was just Ben who
speaks Spanish from French and English
and English he speaks English and he
looked at me like
that's an odd question
but I realized you know I heard myself
say it and I thought that's interesting
because that joke you know sometimes I
will prepare
for a joke and I will wait sometimes
many years for the opportunity to arise
and the joke will emerge and it will
either go well or fall flat but anyway
it's a conscious thing
this was nowhere in my conscious mind my
subconscious mind had that one cued up
ready to go why right so did it get hit
no no
no but I also have no idea why it
crossed the road it just did and uh
somehow myself so he ran all the way
across yeah I see yeah yeah
um but anyway uh I thought it was
interesting because it suggests
something about the subconscious Minds
um construction I don't think it could
possibly have been
it must have been queued up somehow
it's interesting you're still you're set
up I didn't I didn't get it because I
don't think of uh
the why did the chicken cross the road
is is not about an imminent like it it
doesn't right it doesn't Place us
at any particular moment otherwise so in
this case I thought the why was about
like why now like what are you doing
what is wrong with you oh yeah there's
lots of reasons to ask that question but
I know why I asked it and I just didn't
see it coming and you also don't have an
answer
no I don't know although it did remind
me I can't remember him I'm a little
frustrated that I can't remember did I I
once constructed very consciously a uh a
a joke in this genre did I talk about it
on Dark Horse here I'll try it on you
either way your producer eldest son and
I don't know you're we don't know both
rolling your eyes at me simultaneously
no we're just strugging our shoulders
like all right
why did the dinosaur cross the road
because it was chicken
oh
okay yeah okay I like that one yeah it's
a well-constructed joke yeah it didn't
result in a tremendous amount of
laughter which is usually not a good
sign but uh but anyway yeah it is what
it is
no I like it yeah it's phylogenetics
it's it's a thoughtful joke it's just
thought it's phylogenetic it includes a
double entender you know it's a it's a
it's a it's a well-constructed joke
yeah no it is yeah it's good yeah
all right all right yeah maybe I'm at
the end
of Columbia for right now okay um well
that's that's all awesome uh
I hope we uh
I hope the three of us get to go back
there with you at some point oh
absolutely
um sorry Doug you're probably not
included in that
um but she gets other Adventures doesn't
she does she does
all right I want to talk a little bit
about
um
the aft
hmm which is
um
it's afd Washington is a state quote
from their website is a state Federation
affiliated with the 1.6 million American
Federation of teachers AFL-CIO so this
is
um we get we get this this publication
still because when Evergreen faculty
voted to become unionized many years ago
several years before we left that's a
whole story into itself which we are not
going to go into now but Evergreen
faculty voted to become unionized and
when that happened we became members of
afd Washington and began to receive
their publication and somehow despite
our very public departure from Evergreen
they did not catch on so we continue to
receive this publication and they've
continued to send it to us even with our
changes of Interest so I don't even know
what's going on yeah but um we got their
newest edition while you were in
Colombia and I took a look because
um these these Publications often prove
interesting and and this one did
uh basically I'm even more worried about
the state of education now than I was
before I took a look at at this
uh there's a piece in here
called disinformation and journalism the
shape of the landscape okay so again
this is the publication of effectively
the um T the teachers at teachers union
including
um many people in higher ed uh
Washington branch that represents the
you know the unions for most educational
most Educators across the US who are who
are unionized which isn't all but as
many
so
um this whole piece again disinformation
and journalism the shape of the
landscape the whole piece is really
deeply slanted as you might expect right
it's um
it finds nothing but truth and honor
over in democrat's side and sort of
error and conspiracy thinking on the
other side it just it makes claims that
whatever Republicans have said is
clearly missing disinformation and
whatever Democrats have said is not
um and the problem the article States
boldly uh about halfway through
is that the Miss and disinformation are
explicitly political and you know this
this they are telling us is what the
problem is
so uh specifically this paragraph and
I'm going to come back to this paragraph
but this paragraph in this piece is
disinformation is intensely political
pen America which is an aft partner did
a survey of journalists last year that
included a question about which
potential sources of disinformation are
the most egregious cases
76 percent of respondents said
right-wing conspiracy theorists 70 said
politicians are political organizations
left-wing conspiracy theorists and
foreign government actors didn't even
come close at 35 and 30 respectively
our entire political landscape is being
reshaped by misinformation
so
um
I'm going to read that paragraph again
after I talk a little bit about what I
found on the pen America and the AFT
websites because
oh you didn't find Miss and
disinformation did you
I think I did yeah yeah yeah
um I mean I guess you're not very
surprised by that are you you're not not
as surprised as I might be oh my God
yeah so um
at the top of penicillin let's just
let's just launch right now I'm like
okay well Pan America did a survey of
journalists so journalists we know to be
very left-leaning right and let's see
what Pan America is this survey of
left-leaning people done by what kind of
an organization to see how much we can
trust the survey results
at the top of pan America's website we
have a link to their most recent report
which is titled reading between the
lines race equity and book publishing
and here's an excerpt and this is not
yet one of the screenshots I sent you
Zach an excerpt from uh the piece that's
at the top of pen America's website is
recent activism and reform efforts have
pressed for a broad scope of actions to
overcome systemic racial inequities in
the publishing industry and Achieve
sustained holistic and structural change
pen America's research and interview
suggest that measuring and addressing
racial representation in employee hiring
author lists and published content are
key metrics for evaluating long-term
diversification
okay so we got
um you know affirmative action 2022
Edition you know the the most egregious
and actually anti-inclusive and nastiest
form of frankly racism that's happening
and Publishing today uh is being uh
explored and uh appreciated by Pan
America
um also at the top of pen America's
webpage then there you can show the next
screenshot if you will Zach they
retweeted the author
um of an LA Times op-ed which reads
um
the Tweet yeah yeah okay
and then we'll go to the next one but um
yeah so that's too small for me to see
let me just uh no it's fine uh I'll just
pull it up because I didn't have it up
yet uh so this is a tweet by an author
um that Pan America has retweeted
uh if Elon Musk follows through on his
promise to create open season for
disinformation on Twitter he will risk
destroying free speech in one of our
Global villages in the name of trying to
save it doesn't sound very good it
doesn't sound very good at all and when
you click through on that LA Times op-ed
uh what you find among other things is
you can go to the next
the next thing is this paragraph quote
this is again from the LA Times op-ed
when arenas for public discourse are
flooded with this information Free
Speech begins to shed its value if
audiences lose their grip on what is
true and what is false they can become
primed to distrust everything and it
becomes impossible to persuade people
even with the most compelling argument
or evidence
if platforms are riddled with propaganda
on political falsehoods aimed to skew
election results prospects for genuine
discourse on matters of public policy or
local Affairs evaporate if the search
for Reliable information yields nothing
but a morass of co-mingled facts and
falsehoods people eventually stop
searching
so
clearly having recently come back from
from Colombia I am in a a mindset to try
to translate please do and my sense of
what they have just said is that they
had to destroy free speech to save it
yes that's exact that's exactly what
they said furthermore the examples they
give here include like you you can point
to places where the so-called left the
Democrats have done exactly the things
that they're talking about
um trying to fight against but they
don't recognize that the idea that the
2016 election was affected by democrats
who were coming in and trying to
um trying to make sure that Trump
couldn't possibly be elected never shows
up in these analyzes
asymmetry asymmetry is the weapon
underlying all of this yes the
asymmetric application of whatever
standard or definition you you want to
apply the whole thing is done whether
you're talking about detecting fraud in
scientific Publications whether you're
talking about
um accusations of some moral defect any
of these things it just requires you to
take the standard and point it at those
people and you know
do anything necessary to prevent it from
being applied to your own side that's
right that's right so as it turns out
the author of that piece in the early
times which was retreated by pen America
is no other than the chief executive of
pen America
so the organization pen America that did
this survey to assess whether or not
there was political bias and miss and
disinformation in U.S journalism right
now
has just a little bit of a problem with
political bias okay just a little bit
okay so aft let's just go and check out
aft's site so this is again I think it
stands for the American Federation of
teachers although um and again they're a
branch of the AFL-CIO which is the
largest educational basically Union that
covers Educators in the U.S
um
in a piece near the top of their site
aft site uh called pulling together to
end the pandemic
which is not brand new even though it's
near the top of their site which was
written as vaccine mandates descended in
the summer of 2021
they write this is the end of this piece
every one of our members plays a vital
role in our state schools communities in
the lives of Washington students as well
as in the Union
staying safe and keeping others safe by
doing what you can whether that's
masking or vaccinating or both is as
essential as you are the more we pull
together the faster we get the boat
we're all in out of the pandemic grab an
ore and let's pull
I think they've revived the canoe
metaphor
oh I hadn't spotted that but you're
right this is uh this is the canoe
metaphor oh my God and it's also
yeah I mean I guess this is uh when did
you say it was written uh summer of 2021
summer of 2021 I think it it's so 30 14
months ago back when people still bought
the idea that they now claim they never
said that these things blocked uh
transmission they're lying yeah yes
right yes exactly yes uh but this was uh
as uh inslays the second Washington
State this was this Inslee had already
declared mandates for
um
I think it was I think it was K-12
Educators and then separately many of
the colleges had had mandated for their
employees and then a state politician
who actually we knew someone who worked
on his campaign had said no no you got
to mandate more widely
um so this is someone who would run on
an extremely liberal Progressive uh
agenda who's now saying you know
definitely force people to do things
that they shouldn't be doing
um
anyway all of which is to say that both
the AFT and Pen America are both
extremely quote unquote left I'm going
to say pseudo left leading organizations
and
the AFT has written this piece decrying
how political and miss and
discrimination is meaning how right-wing
it is and the only piece of evidence
they provide for that is a survey uh of
journalists done by Pan America
journalists are left-leaning pen America
is extremely left-leaning and like and
stupidly so like this I I still insist
on saying pseudo-liberal pseudo left
this isn't it's it's not it's not what
the left stands for right it's the blue
team which claims to be left it's blue
team yes so how many among the smallest
number of right-wing or Centrist
journalists are going to respond to a
survey by pen America when pen America
is what it is how many therefore you
know this is this is a terrible social
science this is terrible logic it's
being used as evidence in a piece uh in
the aft's publication which is
supposedly a piece by and for educators
how are we how do we expect students to
emerge from an educational system that
where the union members are publishing
this kind of crap this total garbage
that is passing for
uh thought and logic and research
it's it feels hopeless like honestly
when I when I read this piece and I
wanted to talk about this specifically
because I think it's so uninteresting
and banal that it would have passed by
most people's notice most people
wouldn't have read it right like why
would you read such a thing but my my
point is
it's everywhere
the really bad Logic the inability to
even track that what you have just cited
as evidence does not constitute evidence
at all and in fact the fact that you
used it as evidence suggests that you
couldn't find evidence if you needed to
and that the problem may be the reverse
of what you think it is like this this
is extraordinary
it is
I don't think we've come up with a good
term for it yet but the idea that every
Institution
just like maternal instinct is being
turned to its exact opposite that we
have an Academy full of academics who
are learning to avoid doing their job at
an incredible level right yeah we've got
you know presumably thousands of
statisticians who aren't going to spot
the abuse of their discipline we've got
doctors who aren't going to spot a
pattern of medical harm that's right in
front of them and completely avoidable
everybody is going to avoid doing what
they're supposed to be doing and so the
idea that a publication that is
ostensibly about a union of people who
are dedicated to elevating to
enlightening students as to how to think
is going to be confronted with upside
down logic that they will then
steadfastly avoid noticing right I can't
see that it's it's you know at some
point
you've got to see the batter right every
institution is the inverse of what the
thing over the door says right the
Center for Disease controls right the
Center for Disease expansion right
exactly
right so I don't know uh but this isn't
funding expansion
yes exactly it is yeah this public
entity which is supposed to be dedicated
to controlling disease
is actually spreading medical harm and
functioning at the very least on behalf
of private interests right it's it's
upside down and backwards yes it is yes
it is so I know you wanted to say a
little bit about
um Elon Musk and Twitter absolutely um I
thought that pen America uh op-ed uh
that pen America penned LA Times op-ed
uh which uh suggests that musk's taking
over Twitter is the end of the demo of
the world uh and not quite in those
words uh would be a decent segue for you
talking about musk all right so let's
talk about masks so musk obviously is
completing I think now has completed the
deal for Twitter
um he uh revealed this with what I think
is just
um
an epic stunt in which he carried a sink
into the building and said that he had
now taken over Twitter let that sink in
which is so clever that's good yeah it's
really really good I I I'm a big fan of
it anyway I will say I find
thoughtful people who worry about things
like freedom of expression uh
uh informed consent these kinds of
issues are divided over whether or not
musk represents a huge win for those of
us who believe in traditional liberal
values including Free Speech or whether
musk is a cynical entity who is abusing
the trust of those of us who want to see
this is a very positive move
I find it interesting that we are
divided over this I must say I believe
those who are cynical about this those
who see
his move as cynicals who see it as
they're not necessarily being cynical no
they're being cynical they see I think
they're being cynical in the sense that
something positive at the rare positive
thing happens and they are so mired in
recognizing how bad things are that they
can't even see that they have uh that we
are in a better position today than we
were a week ago
I don't I I'm just I'm just objecting to
the idea that that's an inherently
cynicism on their part well I think I
think it is exactly cynicism because
they what they are doing is they are
being reflexive applying a conclusion
yeah this is just more of the same to
something that is actually I think a
hundred percent unique and at the very
least
um difficult to
[Music]
um to assess in terms of its impact so
what uh what do you make of it then so
first of all long time viewers of
Darkhorse will have heard us say many
times that zero is a special number and
the argument needs repeating it's a it's
a really important one the idea is
if there was a university
where they still believed in truth
seeking and would subjugate all other
values to it right well
all the reasonable people would seek to
send their kids there right were there a
newspaper or a newsroom of any kind
that would decide you know what
business-wise we're going to take a
gamble let's do journalism let's figure
out what happened let's not think about
whether or not this is good for our team
in fact we don't have a team we're just
gonna pursue the truth team truth yeah
team truth if team truth had a newsroom
you know what instant economic winner
everybody would want that publication
even if they had an ideology and they
still subscribed to their ideological
thing they would subscribe to the
objective thing so they knew what was
going on before they got around to
screwing up the analysis with their
political stuff right everybody would do
it so it's indeed mysterious that there
isn't a single University that still
functions a single Newsroom that takes
advantage of the giant demand for actual
journalism right why is there no
platform in which you know you have
access to
everybody and free speech is the
value that is pursued right obviously we
all want to go to a place where we can
listen to what we want to listen to and
yes a lot of people will listen to
garbage if we do that but the point is
it's a winning economic strategy why it
doesn't exist so basic argument is
zero is a special number the number of
functional universities has to be zero
the number of functional newsrooms has
to be zero right the number of
functional uh online encyclopedias in
which you can actually check out whether
something is or isn't true has to be
zero
what musk has done here is he has made a
credible play for taking the number from
zero to something that isn't zero he's
gone non-zero and I'm resisting saying
from zero to one because that is of
course the title of Peter thiel's book
and I don't mean to evoke it here
um
but the point is a world in which any
property that has access to the
population at large is a safe space to
use a Charged term for the discussion of
real stuff for the pursuit of Truth for
candid conversations any place in which
that's actually the governing principle
is a mortal danger to Goliath right
Goliath needs the number to be zero
today the number is marching towards
non-zero and what's more there's
actually
uh an interesting phenomenon which I
really didn't see coming
not only do you have musk having taken
Twitter private with the explicit uh
desire to make it a place where speech
is free with some limits yet to be
described but basically erring in the
direction of free speech right but we
also have Jack Dorsey who is
um bringing a platform online with
apparently Dorsey was the Twitter he was
and he stepped down and he's got some
new project he does it's I believe
called Blue Sky so I don't think I mean
people have seen it but I think the beta
opened yesterday if I understand
correctly what's more you have Rumble
making a credible play against YouTube
right now one of these properties
functioning well what do you see as The
Dorsey property what what is it making
it play against like what what what part
of the social media or media Market is
it in well I don't know I haven't seen
it on the inside but my sense it's
unclear to me how it fits with the other
two it's a it's something I'm forgive me
Jack if I've got this wrong but I think
it's something in the neighborhood of a
Twitter 2.0 kind of phenomenon at some
place where discussion would happen that
would be governed by different uh
principles
um but anyway
all that really has to happen is one of
these three plays has to function and
all the better if it were two or three
of them right because then one can get
compromised and it doesn't Rob the
landscape it doesn't take us back to
zero so
what I want to convince people of is
that a I don't know if musk is for real
but I everything I see everything I know
from all of those years that we did
professoring and all of the unusual
people that we knew all of the students
this does strike me as a guy who's made
so much money that he can afford to
gamble this amount on something more
interesting than money which is I think
what he's doing I'm not sure that this
is a business play my guess is he's not
surrendering the business okay but if
the idea is all right look he's a guy
who wants to bring internet to everybody
you know using uh starlink right he
wants to take humans to Mars This is a
guy who gambles on big interesting stuff
and while I have concerns about what
starlink does to the sky I have concerns
about all of these Technologies I think
I understand the human being the human
being is somebody who you know
a
uh to quote Jim rutt uh knows how to
execute
right this is a guy who isn't just an
idea guy he knows how to execute and get
stuff done B he
I think he's bored with the Tyranny
right and I mean you know look he's been
part of it at times he was
um you know a vaccine proponent and all
but the point is I think well a
proponent and a proponent of mandates
proponent of these vaccines a permanent
mandate is very different I don't think
being a proponent of the vaccines is
inherently uh a tyrannical move oh I
don't see a tyrant that's that's kind of
what I'm saying you you you said that as
evidence that he had been somehow over
in tyranny territory
I think what I look I'm watching a human
being very unusual one right this is a
really unusual person and this is
somebody who has interesting interests
which some of them are frightening you
know the neural link stuff I don't know
where that leads
um I don't love the idea that people are
going to look to Mars and think maybe we
don't have to worry so much about the
Earth but
none of it matters the real question is
is this guy
good to his word is he doing what he
says he's doing you know I have no doubt
that he is delighting beating rotten
people at their own game right I know
that that's got to be driving him but I
also do have the sense he is he is
interested in creating a platform where
the conversations that need to happen
can happen Twitter's an interesting
place to do it by far not the biggest of
these properties but it is a place where
journalists and scientists and other
people whose opinions actually do change
things
duke it out and so
anyway I'm uh
I'm hopeful I don't see a better play on
the horizon anywhere and the key thing
for our audience who knows what zero is
a special number means is that that is
why this is important it's not the first
of many battles the argument of zero is
a special number is that if the number
is zero we lose if the number is
anything other than zero we win which
means
you better watch himself that
unfortunately the amount that is at
stake here is the kind of stuff that
Goliath pulls out the Exotic tools to
deal with
and you know we've already seen the
threat of an investigation you know that
they're going to go after his businesses
they're going to investigate him for
attempting that they being
the powers that be and the properties
they own but there's you know there's
going to be a legal investigation into
his business dealings looking for who
knows that sounds like a governmental
thing yeah it is um that's what I was
asking who is they here well I don't
think they is the government I think
they is whatever has captured the
government and uses it for its purposes
but the basic point is look I don't
think that's the limit of the hazard
that comes from making a move as
audacious as this one so
anyway it is what it is he's a very
smart guy certainly he is aware that he
is up against
um the most ferocious concentration of
power that is ever existed I think yeah
um but you know if anybody's up to it he
he probably is
and he also you know he
if you think about
I'm gonna
and mention
he who should typically not be mentioned
but if you think about what Trump did
part of what Trump did that appealed to
people so much
okay sorry sorry
um
Trump
played
in social media space yeah right he gave
himself and every man kind of Vibe by
you know through Twitter really right
remember the speech he gave
um in which he rickrolled everybody
watching the speech no
so he gave a speech in which he
basically you know and yes I had a
particular aversion to watching Trump as
many people who would always voted
Democrat did but I have to say I haven't
really watched political speeches in a
very long time because they're all just
antagonizing and horrifying terrible and
Trump uh was no order he was very very
difficult to listen to yeah but he
actually rickrolled people like he in
the speech he says you know you know
he's talking to Americans he says uh you
know I'm Never Gonna Give You Up I'm
Never Gonna Let You Down and everybody
was watching it who was familiar with
this was like wait what did he just do
that you know so anyway but the point is
all right
it was a kind of a humanizing playful
thing and that's that's CIS genius right
there right I don't want to say
humanizing playful but is uh figuring
out how to get the attention and loyalty
of people even if you know
even if and sometimes because by means
that antagonize and polarize such that
you get you know
you know at least some size of group
that hates you so fiercely that uh as
fiercely as this group over here that
now loves you right right so which is
which amount was also the game the
Democrats are playing and maybe they're
playing it all along too but he was the
one who was like this this is what I'm
gonna do right and you know the
Democrats try this right they just want
us good at it yeah they're not as good
at it yeah right you know they tried to
they found a guy named Brandon uh you
know who they tried they're not they're
not good at it but um but anyway the
point is there is something at the point
I always liked
the battle of the fish on the cars right
where you know Jesus first you had the
Jesus fish and then you had the Darwin
eating the Jesus fish and I can't
remember what the the next Christian
iteration of that battle uh was
um but it was fun it's good but yeah
playful is a good way to play these
things anyway musk is like to my mind
he's like white hat Trump in this regard
he's very good at the meme game right
very wait that Trump okay
um and you know I mean the stunt with
the sink
okay you're the richest guy on Earth
who's just made an audacious play by
buying this one-of-a-kind property in
which the elites of the world battle it
out with box and everybody else right
okay that's serious stuff and what he
does is he walks in with an actual sink
that makes you know him look awkward
because it's not easy to carry like the
dude is playful and he is having a good
time which if you know well he doesn't
seem
it it always seemed like
part of Trump's thing was to create
enemies that the that the that the fact
of an enemy class
which is to say most Democrats
um gave more fuel to his fire gave gave
more cohesion and loyalty to his to his
base whereas I don't get the sense from
musk that he wants or needs enemies
right like he's getting them but he
doesn't I don't think anything he's
doing is uh is after that or depends on
it yeah this is exactly it and actually
I think I think you've you've nailed it
here he did a this is not a needy person
right right yes another big difference
right huge difference the the the needy
powerful man is a very dangerous
phenomenon this guy isn't needy it
doesn't seem to be not needy yeah I will
remind people the day it was announced
that he had become the richest man in
the world musk yeah I didn't know that
was true yeah oh you didn't know he was
the richest man in the world no he's uh
he's very rich and the fact that I
didn't
what's up back and forth and so it
wasn't like a specific point no there
was a well there was a specific specific
point at which it was announced and it
was like the first time you know musk
has become an estate I mean so you're
going somewhere remember that I do think
that this just continues to point out
the difference that you know one of the
things about Trump from well before he
was president was he was always talking
about his wealth right talking about
where he what his standing was and
sometimes it was lies soon as it wasn't
right
um but that's not like Elon just is
right you know I don't I don't think he
ever talks about that standing and maybe
I'm wrong like I honestly don't pay that
much attention his tweet from that day
okay captures it and it could be a
brilliant oh didn't he was like back to
work yeah he was like huh that's odd
back to work yeah yeah and it was like
that is exactly you know I I don't think
anybody ought to really be comfortable
with one individual having that
disproportionate level of power yeah but
if somebody's gonna have that
disproportionate level of power you do
want it to be somebody who regards it as
well okay that happened
it's kind of just an arbitrary fact
right back to work and the fact is the
guy does work yeah he works a lot and he
wasn't yeah he wasn't working to attain
that Benchmark he was working because
he's interested fundamentally in what he
does and we can and should disagree
about whether or not some of those
projects are things that should be
happening and whether or not there
should be you know curtailment Etc but
uh he's not driven by the social
accolades and the public recognition of
him having attained them yeah that I I
must tell you maybe I'm a sucker but I'm
just not in any way frightened by
his values right I may disagree with
them but I don't have the sense that
this is somebody who wants a world that
I would think is terrible and I disagree
well I mean I guess I I see in him a
tech utopian and I find that terrifying
I I I find the tech utopians uh as I
always have
um fairly terrifying and I think that
he's got uh some naivete around you know
around living on Mars for instance right
and around what starlink will do to our
ability to understand our place in the
universe just by looking up at the sky
yep right I agree I agree that that's a
hazard but I guess the point is to the
extent that he's attack utopian I don't
have the sense that he's an
authoritarian right I think he wants to
liberate people and you know he may want
to liberate them to do something that we
would find horrific but
um right you know liberating is is the
key ingredient I'll say one final thing
which is he is now actively
searching and interacting with people on
Twitter about the idea of okay now he's
got it what exactly is he going to do to
moderate it because you can't not
moderate at the very least you have to
um you have to be able to at least
receive uh complaints from people and
have you know things like doxing taken
down you have to adhere to the law yeah
first and foremost and then there may be
things that are leaving absolutely that
are clearly wrong yeah right pedophilia
well that ain't legal but um that's you
said you've got to deal with illegal you
got to deal with the legal stuff first
and then there's stuff that's
this side of the law but clearly wrong
or undesirable for the platform so you
got to moderate it somehow and even with
the legal stuff where you could just say
well that's the law that's the line you
still have to figure out what's over it
right so um so there is a genuine
problem
now
um I tweeted at him yesterday that there
were some people in the game b space
that I thought were very good at these
kinds of puzzles and that you know he
was saying look there's going to be a
council on my point would be there's
some people who have done a bunch of
thinking down this road already the
council
Council to figure out how to how to
moderate Twitter but I would also say
it occurred to me later
that back when game B was a
an actual group of people who met
um
I came up with something like a plan for
governance that was Impractical wouldn't
work it was just a kind of a proof of
concept here's something you could do to
solve the problem but you can't really
do it to a civilization
but it occurred to me you could do it
with Twitter and so anyway I want to
make the offer he wants to reach out to
any of the people we know in common and
you think it'll work
uh yeah I mean it let's put it this way
there's part of the part of the value of
the idea is that it evolves in the right
direction and so
um I think it could work with Twitter
whereas I don't believe there's much
there from the point of view there's no
governance no possibility of a positive
feedback like a runaway process uh the
opposite I think it would inherently uh
tend towards the solution he's looking
for so anyway is what it is all right
well
um there's one more thing you were
thinking about talking about
um yeah it's uh it's kind of heavy okay
but I also feel like people will
understand why it's necessary to talk
about it okay
um I had a very odd experience this
morning
having gotten home yesterday yeah or no
you got a day before yeah yeah okay
um anyway you haven't been home very
long I haven't been home very long I
woke up with the sun this morning
thinking about stuff and I was reading a
few things on my phone
and I read uh Caitlyn Johnstone's piece
about the about how people who depart
from The Narrative on Putin and Ukraine
are viewed and treated it's an excellent
piece I recommend it she's often very
good and she's really excellent at this
particular job so it's good piece then I
read uh read Steve kersh's sub stack in
which to my horror he describes and
provides some evidence surrounding Peter
McCullough having been
um removed from one of his professional
credentials and
um essentially evicted from his role as
editor
of a major journal in his field so this
is a highly decorated doctor with an
incredible publication record who
um Steve Kirsch reveals a personal email
in which Peter McCullough says that he's
been shoved out he's been pushed out of
this journal and that there was no he
wasn't allowed to present his case that
basically he was just given the the uh
the boot over email and certified
letters and then Steve Kirsch reveals
that um he
republishes what the journal says
happened and the journal says that Peter
resigned uh because he had other
basically wanted to go spend more time
with his family or one of those nonsense
things right so it's you can see the two
things side by side
and there's no reconciling them so
something is afoot with respect to that
but anyway at the end of reading Steve
kersh's piece
um I'm not sure exactly what happened on
my phone but somehow the next screen
that showed up was a browser window
and in the browser window was a
DuckDuckGo search as far as I know
already completed on the word suicide
which you had not done I absolutely did
not conduct a search on the word suicide
in
any time in memory and it's not the kind
of thing
you know sometimes I search a word
because I don't know how to spell it I'm
not sure and so I'll circulate in order
to see whether I've got the spelling
right this isn't such a word I know how
to spell it
there was no explanation for why this
browser window with that search would
have come up and obviously phones are
complex
um
I'm sure we can come up with
explanations that would account for this
showing up in that way but I also know
that
we have been a
a Sticky Wicket for Goliath and
one can imagine that such a thing would
you know could scare certain people off
or worse but anyway I thought it was
necessary just to say look I had this
happen
I wonder if other people have had it
happen right that or something similar
where something that could be a message
is delivered in such a way
maybe somebody's got a technical
explanation of how that search could
have happened without
um you know I don't know what it would
be but without it having a nefarious
explanation but
I did think it was necessary to say this
is not
um
this is not
a thought
that occurs to me it's been a very long
time since I've had any thought in that
neighborhood in fact since having a
family you know people have Suicidal
Thoughts occasionally but having a
family
displaces all of that and I
just
thought it was necessary
so that you know look there are
obviously
hundreds of billions of dollars at stake
and criminal liability and all sorts of
things the kinds of things that people
do terrible stuff over and
um
I felt it was necessary just to uh to
make it clear that if that was some kind
of a message then
um
this idea is nowhere in my thoughts the
only time something would have happened
to you yeah and the explanation after an
investigation is suicide you are saying
here and now that it was not well I will
tell you the conditions under which I
would consider it the conditions under
which I would consider it are let's say
that
um
I had a terminal illness
or something so destructive of the
capacity to contribute to my family that
I was much more of a hindrance than I
was a help in such a circumstance
obviously there's an argument for this
or you know under torture that shows no
sign it can end where there is no hope
right such things obviously I don't want
to say never ever ever because there are
circumstances in which this is a
rational response but what I will say is
under you know
um I've got so many reasons not you know
as tough as the world is I have a
wonderful life I have people who are
depending on me whom I love and do not
wish to strand I do not wish to
traumatize them uh I have selfish
reasons
to want to live I do not see how this
works out yeah I do not like the idea of
uh dying and not getting to know how
stuff that I was part of ended up right
that just that Galls me a little bit
that that can happen to you so well
there's there's going to be some things
left hanging sure sure but you know the
big stuff that's in play I'd kind of
like to know how it ends up
um so yeah so anyway
um
I think it is uh
I mean I think the job is done maybe it
was a technical glitch if it wasn't a
technical glitch maybe it was just a
message design to scare if it wasn't
that if it was a warning uh I don't
scare easily and I uh you know
um we can't afford to have a world
that's governed by people who um
threaten as a mechanism to get what they
want so
whatever the explanation is here I feel
the discussion needed to be had and uh I
don't know I feel better for having done
it all right
well I think that brings us to the end
of this almost two hours but we're gonna
take a break and come back for our q a
afterwards and we'll begin with a
question uh from our Discord server this
week as we always do
another reason to get onto our Discord
server which you can get access to from
our patreons and then we'll be taking
questions from you which uh not from you
so much because you can ask questions
all day long all day long
um you can ask questions at
darkhorsesmissions.com
and I guess that's one other thing I
wanted to say which I should also start
putting the announcements at the
beginning next week which is that at
some point uh probably near the end of
November maybe beginning of December
we're going to do an episode not at our
usual time basically talking about just
different just talking about stuff
products that we like that aren't
sponsors uh that often made by local
producers small producers that that we
have come to really appreciate as a sort
of a like if if you do that sort of
thing as the holiday season is coming up
things that you might consider as
um as as gifts for those that you might
be interested in in buying gifts for and
so although uh this could result in no
emails at all it could result in an
awful lot I will say that our Dark Horse
moderator gmail.com email
darkhorsemoderator gmail.com can receive
uh suggestions
um
and
what else I think we'll be back in 15
minutes or so with that q a and in the
intro and until we see you again for the
main episode same time same place next
week be good to the ones you love eat
good food and get outside be well
everyone
[Music]